for number one singles and just recently
three gold certified singles - how good
is it - making right now come on
[Music]
hey welcome to certified country I'm
selfish Laci joining me today is Matthew
Ramsey from Old Dominion thank you so
much for being here now I got to ask you
the first question where is the rest of
your band you guys are killing it right
now fourth number-one single
congratulations how exciting is that
still fourth time around oh it's never
gets old
you know I mean we as writers that's
kind of what we set out to do was to you
know write hit songs so now we get to be
in a band that's performing these hit
songs it feels different
when it's at the top of the chart and
you play it to a crowd I'm always
curious about with bands what the
dynamic is you know do you go out and
work on your own individual projects
here and there are you kind of a package
deal how does that work with you I mean
we do go out and work on songs it's not
like anybody's going out to make an
album or anything but sometimes we'll
write I'll go write with a couple of
other writers and you know or Trevor or
Brad we'll go write with somebody and
but we still bring those songs to the
table and say hey check out this song
and sometimes they'll get excited about
it or sometimes they're like s not as
good as you think it is you and I were
talking earlier off-camera about your
kids being critics of your music well
you know when you have a hit song when
they are just like play that would play
that one play that one we always talk
about our kids being a great way to
judge whether or not it's a hit song
because there's something very basic
about the way they perceives in music
that I think needs to be there if it's
gonna be a hit you know like you can
overthink it a lot but there's something
very basic about a hit song and if a kid
can get it then you got a good chance I
think are they your harshest critic I
mean in some ways yes in some ways they
just love everything they're not old
enough yet to like think I'm not cool a
little bit as a former winner tell me a
little bit about what that award means
to you guys as a band you know that was
such a surprise to us like that year was
just this explosion of like man we're
we're on the scene now I guess everyone
always says it and everyone always says
it sounds cliche but it's because it's
true it really is you know it really is
an honor to be nominated everyone who is
in this industry works really hard then
and there are lots of different ways
that you can see the fruits of that
labor and this is one of them that lets
you know that everyone else who's who's
also working hard at it recognizes you
and it's a it's a nice way for your
peers to to say like man we're rootin
for you and it feels good
[Music]
please talk my rebo a little bit and how
many things she is she's clean man she's
yeah when she speaks you just want to
hear what she says she's just like I
love her because she doesn't take
herself too seriously
she's just so it she has that same kind
of thing that dolly has in that men they
are just so 100% themselves that it's
it's you know it's very captivating to
watch someone like that I'm just
thrilled faces now I want to get to know
you a little bit better with this
rapid-fire round first album you ever
purchased Don Henley okay
first concert you attended Huey Lewis
and the news alright song currently
spinning on repeat it's bad band called
whisky town it's Ryan Adams is band
before he was Ryan Adams there's a song
on there called Jacksonville if you were
an artist you'd probably be doing what I
would be probably a visual artist I went
to school for illustration okay I have a
degree in that so that my new year's
resolution this year was to make our
ticket so I've done a few pieces the
last one is one thing we've never
guessed by looking at you
my brother has blond hair and blue eyes
thank you guys so much for watching be
sure to subscribe to entertainment
tonight on YouTube we'll be back with a
brand new episode of certified country
next Friday we'll see you then
you